[موسيقى]
مكعب صغير واحد يحل محل
الفاكهة أو الخضار الكاملة على سبيل المثال ،
بدلاً من
تناول
الجزر ، يمكنك تناول
مكعب واحد فقط
بالطبع ، فالوجبة الطازجة دائمًا ما يكون الطعام الطازج
هو الخيار الأفضل ، لكن في بعض الأحيان
لا يكون لدينا وقت نسارع عندما
نسرع  السفر ، لذا فإن
اللدغات خيار جيد جدًا
لتناول وجبات خفيفة صحية
[الموسيقى]
هذه طابعة طعام لوجبة خفيفة مبتكرة
وفي مكعب صغير واحد أصبحت كمية كبيرة
من القيمة الغذائية
للفيتامينات والمعادن
وأصبحت الحاجة إلى
مثل هذه الوجبة الخفيفة بسبب اتباع نظام غذائي سيء
وعادات تناول وجبات خفيفة غير صحية
[موسيقى] في
بعض الأحيان ليس لدينا وقت على الإطلاق
لتناول الطعام ،
لذا فإن اللدغات
تحل كل المشاكل.
أساس اللدغات وطابعة الطعام لدينا
هي
تقنية التجفيف بالتجميد ،
هذه الطريقة التي طورتها وكالة ناسا الفضائية
في هذه الطابعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
للوجبات الخفيفة
التي نستخدمها
مسحوق
من الشحوم الغذائية المجففة
وهذا المسحوق مضغوط
[موسيقى
] وحتى الآن هي الطريقة الأكثر
فاعلية لحفظ الطعام
وبدون أي إضافات بدون مكونات إضافية
تجميد الأطعمة المجففة المحفوظة  جميع
الفيتامينات والمعادن والمواد الغذائية
يمكننا تجميدها مجففة
تقريبًا كل شيء ،
نعم من التوت والفواكه والخضروات وأيضًا
آيس كريم
الحليب والزبادي والسوائل المختلفة التي
يحبها الأطفال ونعلم أن
الأطفال
لا يحبون تناول الخضار وهنا يقولون
إنها شوكولاتة الجزر  أو ما
هي عضاتنا ، لذا من الجيد جدًا سماعها
[موسيقى]